surtout ne touche à rien ne bougeait pas
rester avec nous reste de l'actualité
avant toute chose je voudrais savoir
team monsieur ici à bonheur machines
taillées à peu près quoi 7 60% les trois
premiers rangs un peu près france à voir
c'est normal une fois n'est pas coutume
ce matin là on ne débat pas du sujet du
reportage
parce qu'on fait tout simplement
l'unanimité le prof a même été remplacé
par tonio 25 youtuber au 1 million 200
mille abonnés qu'est ce qui vous a amené
à vouloir faire ce sujet je regardé
beaucoup de vidéos sur youtube de gaming
de toutes sortes j'avais vraiment envie
de savoir
enfin comment ça se passait derrière la
caméra comment on va voir des corps
voilà la vérité des corps j'ai choisi le
sujet d'une étude parce que je pense que
c'est un peu plus à un truc de jeunes
fin et que tout le monde ne connaît pas
et que ça vient de le faire connaître à
tous je me suis plutôt pour le gaming
ici toi tu joue à call of duty depuis
qu'en bas depuis deux ans bah je sais c
est sur la côte d'azur parce que je
voyais comme att fort tu faisais des
nucléaire et tout bas ça m'intéresse a
pu moi aussi je me mettais au défilé
je ne veux pas moi j'étais suivi plus
pour les vidéos à thème parce que je
trouve ça assez drôle
là
à peine l'entretien terminé avec la
classe les fans youtuber l'attendent
pour des selphy dans les couloirs du
collège
la notoriété du personnage est à la
hauteur du nombre de ses abonnés des
ados pour la plupart entre 13 et 16 ans
exactement le créneau de nos deux
reporters qui lui ont donné rendez vous
chez lui
pour en savoir plus sur les secrets de
son succès donc n'hésitez pas à venir
les comme un matériau mon humble demeure
là où je fais mes vidéos à 24
stonewall a déjà huit ans de pratique
derrière roulis est un univers une
d'abord porté par les jeunes montage
dans le lit puis après on aura fini avec
le avec le groupe et séguéla pour les
rangs du viol est peut-être mieux
j'espère que vous allez bien on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour une toute
nouvelle vidéo vous leurrez vu justement
sur twitter je les dis black ops cas tu
vas être gratuit pendant une semaine en
tout cas pour ce qui est du mode battle
royale google vidéos gaming
il nous faut donc un boîtier
d'acquisition dont qui va permettre
d'enregistrer en fait ce qui est diffusé
depuis notre ps4 une caméra un micro
selon moi c'est les trois équipements
nécessaires pour la réalisation d'une
vidéo gaming un minimum de matériel pour
se faire une place au soleil et être
reconnus par les internautes
uniquement des joueurs au départ mais
aussi aujourd'hui des adeptes de ces
vidéos athènes vient de passer l'année
2019 pour ça c'est un secret pour
personne tu le sais et élégant les 2001
vont avoir 18 ans cette année
les termes sur les vidéos on va pas se
mentir principalement la source
d'inspiration c'est les américains après
on apporte toujours une touche
personnelle quand même temps vous avez
mis pour atteindre le million devenait
je crois que j'ai atteint le million
alors j'ai pas envie de dire de bêtises
mais je crois que c'est l'année dernière
au fait merci
un succès qui lui permet de toucher de
l'argent de la publicité diffusée sur
ces vidéos ou des partenariats noués
avec des marques artistes pour autant de
lâcher son emplois d'informaticiens au
conseil départemental avec youtube ya
quand même aussi de la pression donc
tout le temps et c'est d'être productive
tout le temps décide quand même de faire
un certain nombre de vues si tu dois en
vivre en forcément et le fait que je
travaille à côté ça me libère en fait de
cette pression si une vidéo fonctionne
pas si j'ai pas envie de tourner au
moins je me force pas admiratif loin de
l'objectivité requise pour l'exercice
rania inesta nos deux journalistes n'ont
pas résisté à l'envi de tester l'outil
du maître avant de le laisser à son
travail
mais voilà la vidéo les termine en tout
cas j'espère que ça vous aura plu et
c'était pas mettre le petit pouce bleus
à une prochaine vidéo
les gars peace love qui sera la
prochaine